the people of Britain after a long and  exhausting template have finally spoken  and I don't think we need any fancy  constitutional experts to tell us what  they were trying to say I think they  have decisively rejected any attempt to  take this country back to the 1970s I  think they had compassion drive dating  politics of division and it is clear to  me that the people of this country wants  us to go forward with sensual with  sensible moderate policies that this  Conservative Party has produced over the  last five years and an event or a  sustained economic recovering Islander  people in this country want to go  forward with that long-term economic  plan with a benefit forever  all right come